[Laughter]
[Music]
I think you mean nuvaring fell out no I
don't feel like it's in there you can
feel that in the Hat you are lucky you
know that you're free you're free I wish
I was it feels like we're on autopilot
or something
[Music]
are those rocket ships some girls think
it's adorable
mashing me dating some are you guys
actually baby yeah I mean I wouldn't say
that we're dating
they're increasing the rent of this
place in September let's just move in
together I don't want to move in
together okay
things haven't felt right
I am on a break but the guy who I
thought I was going to marry oh no no
I'm not ready to settle down okay well
make you happy
can we look at pictures of sushi on Yelp
yeah
I feel like kind of hitting a wall
sorry I'm kind of seeing someone you
know she made me watch your stupid
little show and I actually liked it he
just lost a viewer to me buddy boy
[Music]
honestly in a lifetime how many people
being truly connected
whose side are you one do you wanna um
get brunch a little woman would never
let me keep my sauces in the car but now
I have them for easy access whenever I
walk it smells really weird in here it's
the smell of freedom
[Music]
you
you